qué tanto puede impactar entonces este
escándalo de los documentos hallados en
la residencia del presidente biden en lo
que resta de su mandato y en
particularmente para este tercer año
bueno primero que todo Muchísimas
gracias por la invitación hay que
analizar lo que encuentre el
departamento de Justicia quien ya
designó a un fiscal encargado para que
lleve a cabo esas investigaciones
obviamente
digamos existen esos paralelos entre los
documentos encontrados en mara lago y
los documentos que se han encontrado en
su residencia en Delaware más lo que se
encontró en las oficinas que él
ostentaba cuando era el vicepresidente
obviamente todavía estamos en esa etapa
preliminar no sé con qué fin el
presidente utilizó esos documentos Así
que creo que hay que digamos analizar un
poco con cautela estos dos casos que
difieren en ese sentido así que vamos a
ver lo que arroje la investigación que
ha lanzado el departamento de justicia a
cargo precisamente del señor Mary carlen
que ha llevado o que anunció
precisamente esta esta investigación se
nos como lo decía comienza el tercer año
para el presidente biden pero es un
tercer año en el que los republicanos
tomaron el control de la cámara baja del
Congreso Allí se espera que los
conservadores por decirlo de alguna
forma
desplieguen toda su artillería pesada
Qué se puede esperar en esa relación
entre el legislativo y El Ejecutivo para
este tercer año Bueno hay que hacer una
aclaración obviamente no es el control
del Congreso tienen el control de la
cámara baja más no tienen el control del
congreso en su totalidad los demócratas
tienen el control del senado por ejemplo
que es una ventaja mínima de la misma
manera que es una ventaja mínima para
los republicanos en la cámara de
representantes obviamente
los republicanos digamos desplegarán
todo su artillería pero también hay que
ver que el presidente tiene a los
demócratas de su lado en el senado y que
también tiene el derecho del del veto
cuando hay políticas que van en
detrimento de lo que él cree y de lo que
él debe como debe manejarse el país es
que obviamente hay que tener en cuenta
esos factores señor Valencia coincide
que este jueves Estados Unidos alcanzó
su actual techo de deuda 31,4 billones
de dólares Qué significa Entonces esto
para las finanzas del gobierno para lo
que resta del mandato y para responder
con los compromisos que tiene Estados
Unidos
Bueno ese es uno de los retos y
precisamente de las asignaturas
pendientes que tiene el presidente biden
y obviamente cualquier tipo de
negociación que haga con los
republicanos y obviamente lo que se haga
en el plano económico pues va a ser
importante de cara precisamente al 2024
cuando se reanude nuevamente Esta
carrera presidencial eh Y esto será
obviamente bueno sé que tengamos pocos
minutos de tiempo y es un tema que puede
dar para mucho pero creo que esa es mi
impresión por lo menos de lo que estamos
viendo hasta el momento con el con el
techo de la